[Musik]
die Bedrohung durch einen feindlichen
Angriff auf Österreich ist nicht zu
unterschätzen doch wir sind gerüstet mit
der Mission vorwärts des
österreichischen
Bundesheeres
[Musik]
Mission vorwärts ist die große
Neuaufstellung des österreichischen
Bundesheeres über den nächsten 10 Jahre
werden über 16 Milliarden Euro in die
Modernisierung des bundeshahres
[Musik]
investiert die Welt um uns verändert
sich und mit ihr die Herausforderungen
denen sich unser Land stellen muss für
die Sicherheit unserer Bevölkerung ist
es erforderlich sich mit einem kampkräft
und modernen herer für aktuelle und
zukünftige Bedrohungen zu rüsten einer
dieser Bedrohungen sind Angriffe auf
unsere
Infrastruktur gegen die Gefahr eines
feindlichen Angriffs von außen rüsten
wir uns auch mit folgenden Maßnahmen
Autarkie im Notfall fällt durch einen
Angriff das Stromnetz großflächig aus
müssen unsere Kasernen und
Kommunikationsnetze autonom
funktionieren deshalb investieren wir in
Digitalisierung mit unabhängigen
führungs und
Kommunikationssystemen Ausbau unserer
cybereinheit wir erhöhen die
Kampffähigkeit und Durchschlagskraft
auch im Cyberspace mit best
ausgebildeten Personal und modernster
Technik Ausbau der Luftraumüberwachung
und Luftabwehr erfolgt ein Angriff aus
der Luft gilt es diesen frühest möglich
zu verhindern deshalb verteidigen wir
unseren Luftraum aktiv und permanent von
Boden aus mit drohnenabwehr und
fliegerabwehrsystemen in der Luft mit
unseren
[Musik]
eurofigh